after you start seeing changes in the
metrics keep testing see if you can
further perfect you're offering landing
page or messaging or whatever it is that
you're testing I don't want you to get
discouraged if your hypothesis was wrong
that's actually great you learn
something new you now know that that's
not what you need to do to improve your
business and you can narrow down other
options and keep working through your
list of ideas so let's hear from tally
who is proven wrong with a hypothesis
she once made so it's interesting we ran
some experiments lately and I'm gonna
say something really controversial and
all the design people are going to be
outraged but what I found out is that
the language and the text that you use
on your landing page have tremendously
more effect than the imagery so it's
interesting right we were trying what
you really want to get right is the
message is what you're saying to people
that the product is and every single
product can be represented probably in
30 different ways so figure those out
and try to find the one sentence that
resonates with your user that they read
the sentence and they say yes this is it
I want to sign up for that and we
experimented a lot with this language
and we improved our conversion rate on
the homepage by hundreds and hundreds of
percentages and then we think this thing
with the imagery and we thought oh now
we will do the imagery and it'll be
another hundred percent increase but not
so much once we found the right language
people just knew they read it they knew
they wanted it and they signed up when
you're setting up an a/b test one of the
things you want to have in mind is
what's the effect that you want to see
usually we start with a metric that we
want to move so for instance if we have
a new product like voice messaging and
we want more people to use it we can
assign a test group in the control group
where we advertise more heavily to the
test group and see how the product is
used differently by the tested control
the first step to diagnosing any problem
that you see in your data is cutting it
by different dimensions so a dimension
can be pretty much anything it can be
country if you have an app that's out
internationally it can be by platform if
you have out on Android and iOS and by
anything else that you know about your
users
that you can use to try and isolate the
issue if for example your app is
abarkment and you suddenly see that the
number of postings that are going up
onto your site have dropped really
heavily you could then cut that by the
different interfaces that people can
post from so you can look at the number
of posts which are coming from iOS from
Android and from your desktop site if
you see that one of those is the one
that's dropping you can then look in the
code and see if you have a problem with
your post an ad for an important thing
to look out for when doing an a/b test
is to make sure that you have enough
people going into either side of your
experiment then you can be confident
that the result that you're seeing is
real and not just a result of random
chance if you google for a B test
significance calculator you can actually
get free online tools where you can put
in the number of people going through
your experiment and the number of people
successfully completing whatever
objective it is you have in mind and it
can tell you what's called a confidence
interval and in the industry
normally we look at @p 95 and that means
for any result that you see you can be
95% sure that the experiment is really
giving the result and it's not just
random chance and also when you found
out which one of your experience is the
better one you can actually roll out
that new user experience to everyone you
can do it without having to go through a
new App Store submission either to the
Play Store or the App Store